it was always when the phone ring and i
saw dana what i was like shoot what are
you what is it gonna come with how long
ago was this yes off uh until um
like until like uh you're a you're okay
yeah yeah got it so but now now it's
over now so now we can talk like two
friends and so how has the relationship
changed
when you said
he would he would call you you would be
like oh what does he want now when you
were active
versus now the the relationship must
have
changed to some some extent right they
know it's normal he's the best promoter
in the world there's a reason why he's
the best promoter in the world he's the
best i don't care don king put anybody i
think dana is the best in the world can
sell
ice to an eskimo you know he's just that
good he's very smart
but to be a good promoter you need to to
use certain tools to be tricky sometimes
and he did what he had to do for the
best of his own interests but i did what
i had to do for the best of my own
interests so sometimes it conflicts each
other